who do you think delivered the greatest
super bowl halftime performance of all
time well bruno mars at super bowl 48.
did you say beyonce or prince
oh okay i thought that's what you said
well here's what we know for sure
in these different and unprecedented
times the weekend show will be like
no other in super bowl history
[Music]
e.t has the exclusive first look at the
weekend super bowl promo
the 30 year old says he's humbled
honored
and ecstatic from a small local venue in
toronto
to the world stage i'm continuing this
journey with my fans
taking them into the next chapter of our
story as your
55th pepsi super bowl halftime show
performer
[Music]
[Applause]
the weekend's halftime show in tampa is
the follow-up to jlo and shakira's
performance
both produced by jay-z and roc nation
jay praised the weekend's soulful
uniqueness
so how will the weekend pull this off
during a pandemic
and will he perform at the stadium
well we do know that the nfl has scaled
back its plans for february super bowl
estimating that only about 20 percent of
the seats at the stadium will be filled
and as for half time the league says it
will work within the safety guidelines
established by local authorities
if the weekend performs remotely don't
worry
he got you
the 30 year old put on a spectacular
remote show
complete with fireworks for the vmas
the three-time grammy winner who has
dated bella hadid and selena gomez
is known to be a little camera shy i
love you guys
and rarely does interviews but he did
open up about his performance anxiety
and needing to be sober on stage i'm not
up there lip syncing
you know i don't got backup dancers it's
all about me
and the microphone